[Applaudissements]
sortie bout avec eux voilà une meuf
genre une correspondante il y avait une
journée correspondant à l'époque moi je
me rappelle que j'avais encore les gens
j'avais deux correspondantes moitié
étaient venus à la maison et en fait je
faisais des pièges dans la mer à chaque
fois je disais ouais tu peux leur
demander genre de demande et du gâteau
et tout et je leur disais à ma mère je
lui disais on peut avoir de la quéquette
tu pourrais voir un bout de qq
être il est né d'atlantie avec des
voiles à dennis green si vous avez
peut-être a sorti avec des allemandes
vous avez une choriste orbite quand
exactement mais tu m'as mis un gros vent
c'était le premier d'une longue série et
voilà c'était quand j'étais au collège
web en tout cas c'est une très belle
année
grâce à un petit point de la
médaille mais je crois qu'il est sorti
avec un canadien un américain à la
mairie car le poids de prof de ski le
ski exactement david wyss appelé très
vite je me rappelle et me ouais je vous
rappellerai trèbes autres ils avaient un
bon flocons
quand vous n'êtes pas content de ce qui
c'était bon c'était non ce n'est pas mon
prof de ski c'est un prof de ski de la
station il plantait le bâton
j'avais 18 ans et je les trouvais c'est
est l'archétype de l'américain comme on
imagine l'américain avec la grèce quand
on voit la belle éthique beau gosse et
c'est donc voilà c'était mon
nom mais la vitrine non mais vous à lui
sorti andy macdowell ouais c'est vrai
c'est que c'est fou parce que vous vous
êtes sorti qu'on dit maintenant
[Rires]
je n'ai pas été très bons pour tout vous
dire pourquoi sa durée oui oui oui
exactement bon sens veut pas savoir
12 minutes quoi un truc et on s'en doute
ajouté
mais j'étais tout jeune journaliste on
que pourquoi le madiba la montée et j'ai
fait mon thème des déshabillés vous mais
c'est sûr qu'à tes pas médecin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dim est une photo dans des mcdo est mort
et ils sont déjà partis dès vendredi
c'est le week-end mais c'est certain on
s'en fout de l'année devant
alors je vous le dis les actrices
américaines prennent souvent les
nouveaux c'est vrai moi ça m'est arrivé
à haïti robbie williams sharon stone
à l'époque i'm a dit king sting pareil
bahia n'a pas convoqué elle m'a dit
déshabiller ou hélas éclaté vers moi du
peu parce
que vous feriez tort c'est une femme
était entreprenante comme ça est
vraiment vous donne ma voix là vous vous
dites je te veux des habits toi
maintenant tout de suite
je ne suis pas là dedans mais son boulot
dans l'émission affaires non mais c'est
lors de l'émission non mais c'est vrai
vous êtes vous vous avez déjà donc sorti
cet été à santec david break vous à lui
si le web correspondance allemande aussi
parce que j'habitais dans l'est et moi
c'était la première langue obligatoire
c'est tellement parce que c'était juste
après la guerre froide donc c'était
allemande ig à thouaré dont je suis à
lherm allemagne à francfort ah oui bah
oui c'est une autre époque à francfort
et je suis sorti qu'une correspond
totalement j'avais 17 ans peu près et sa
théorie parce que c'est on n'a pas été
jusqu'au ciel ses amis elle avait des
poils sous les bras
même pas baisser les bras
mais vu ça et on n'a pas idée comment
s'arrêter là je jardine
sécateur
j'ai eu la même veine autre chose sauf
la même histoire mais avec un italien et
sap et giancarlo il était sublime
cherchant ferrari en fin d'année par les
italiens j'adorerais je peux pas je peux
à l'époque j'ai 22 ans 23 ans un truc
comme ça j'adorais effectivement quand
il s'est déshabillé j'ai eu le même
problème non alors oui j'ai pas alors je
jean-karl où il n'a pas joué dans ta
touche m'étouffe
[Rires]
les invités dont je n'ai jamais vu ça de
ma vie et moi je connais avait un tapis
poil dans le dos non
sur les épaules est tout ouïe dans la
fda gentil lèvera la carte de l'italie
dans le dos presque emploi jerry ça
passe avec une ferrari
5e devant c'était très bizarre enfin
même là je ne suis pas allé jusque là
j'ai vu en fait j'ai vu en maillot de
bain j'ai vu les ducks qui m'avait
emmené à la mer et tout le monde est
super on était sûr tu vas la riviérette
c'était génial mais on n'est pas allé
jusqu'à ouais c'est pas possible on
aurait dit rien d'un gorille enfin les
postiers maman c'est à écouter ça va lui
faire plaisir si
en italien alors vous ne m'avez pas de
correspondant à l'époque
[Rires]
comment ça se passe et de grottes à
grotte
à
ma droite il l'a pas beaucoup vu parce
qu'il s'appelait yann bramsen il était
anglais il soutenait arsenal et nous
pour rire avec une copine on a soutenu
l'équipe adverse wolverhampton et il m'a
dit jamais de la vie je coucherais avec
une fille qui ne soutiennent pas arsenal
aurait été fini sympa elle est belle et
belote de la région
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fait moi j'ai envie de faire une étude
psychologique a dit à quel moment ça se
dit j'ai peut-être à mumbai
on est sur les anecdotes de cause je
pense faisant montre eu quelques
histoires de 500 canards
je pense qu'on
peut faire mouche gilbert baise moi je
suis sorti avec une correspondante
anglaise maïs bête lisbeth richmond dans
la banlieue de londres sur sa douce sur
sa pelouse qui était ton du haras comme
ça on garde et wimbledon aux n'était pas
nommé
elle s'est jetée sur moi non oui ouais
j'avais 13 ans elle était bloquée à
dénouer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fois que c'est marine
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
alors sincèrement je n'ai jamais de
correspondants fait jamais
mais ces jeunes face à l'alcool métier
s'est passé déjà les sentiers qui m'a
fait ni trop
facile étrangères de nouveau
à quel moment ça s'écrit pas
[Rires]
c'est une actrice qui a joué dans
l'affairisme et en os si oui
mais c'est vrai qu'elles sont très
entreprenants tous les américains alors
comment s'y passait avec celle ci une
très grande actrice et une très grand
raté j'étais très surpris moi je te dis
j'avais la radio j'avais la radio à
saint tropez et puis elle est venue
boire elle bénéficiera de saint-tropez
oui oui oui on fait ça pendant deux ans
et en 95 mais vous fait qu'après autant
qu'à arrêter c'était assez difficile de
faire ça tout l'été elle est venue en
bois très sympa et puis elle me dit
voilà j'aime je sais que tu connais tout
le monde moi j'étais émerveillé de les
rencontrer les moyens le cinéma est donc
de les amener chez johnny je l'amenais
chez juliette gréco jeu les amener chez
michel maure gants et gérard oury ouais
ouais elle voulait vraiment original
était déjà mis avec régine elle voulait
connaître un peu tout le monde pineau
tout ça voilà et c'est très sympathique
et de quoi voilà et voilà ça a été
mais c'est quoi l'histoire alors tu
laquelle joue pas oui on a été pas
paralysé sur un bateau effectivement ou
les photos sans succès quoi sur le
bateau tout relevé le coup tu l'avais la
paix chanter mais la photo elle est
claire on était en couverture de paris
match malheureusement
way et ça a été sacrée merde pour moi je
peux vous dire ça m'a créé beaucoup de
problèmes à l'époque j'étais tf1 etienne
mougeotte m'appelle et me dit [ __ ]
bernard mais qu'est ce que tu fais c'est
mon idole je suis très en colère mais
elle était vraiment en colère quand je
suis rentrée des vacances il m'a
convoqué il m'a dit arrête tes conneries
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire en
fait c
megan a été choquée et en couverture de
paris match malheureusement away est bon
nous ont heureusement on est restés très
amis je les revues à los angeles etc
mais là elle a beaucoup changé elle
n'était pas contente en tire
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
delphine savoir pourquoi mais ça va me
faire du mal
c'est mignon c'est très mignon j'étais
tombé un peu amoureuse ça j'avais eu un
coup de coeur pour un géo au club med
entier et
du coup
ils allaient faire de l'aquagym et ans
et c'est vrai que l'été car en était
vraiment beau musclé t il était
magnifique on n'a pas ça ici eh bien
nous
on m'a donné rendez-vous il m'a un peu
coincé comme ça contre un mur on en
voulait m'embrasser j'étais trop timide
et j'ai dit non à cannes note comme ça
et du coup il m'a juste donné son petit
numéro de téléphone sur un papier mais
ce n'est pas encore l'air de whatsapp et
donc voilà donc ce papier je les gardais
très longtemps dans ma table de nuit et
puis un jour je les ai perdus et cteep à
l'ère des réseaux sociaux non plus donc
la seule chance est de cesser qui
s'appelait chahine et jeanne shaheen
s'est insurgée la boîte de nuit le
sunshine
cdc nous retrouver
c'était courte histoire mais c'était un
non non pas du tout non j'avais genre
des 17 ans ah ouais
l'aquagym il est sous l'eau
là c'est terminé bien entendu ajouter
bien maintenant il ya quoi elle va ça
installe